everyone there's a steeple on Trobe with
Collider and I am here with the team
behind Olympic dreams how are you guys
doing we're great I just told you
off-camera that I'm hungry right and
that's because they're working you to
the bone literally where they're making
a seed human bone right it's not healthy
actually maybe it is healthy there's a
bone you guys you do bone yeah actually
just yesterday I found in a turkey leg I
got a food truck and ate it all the way
down to the bone and really was like a
turkey leg like a Renaissance Fair yes
it was gigantic and everywhere I went
people are asking me where I got it so I
think they actually sell turkey legs at
Disneyland and it's like one of their
big things there I always think about
like those animated movies where they're
like where a guy eats like a turkey and
that like he eats the last piece of meat
off the bone like that those are the
kinds of things I'm thinking about
before we go any further I just realized
I need to give a huge thank you we're at
South by Southwest and I want to give
you huge thank you to our sponsors like
hint water and blue moon and everyone at
supper sweet because without them we
couldn't actually support movies like
this so I just wanna give a huge thank
you
so I want to jump in and say that this
is such a unique film that you guys
actually got to film like at the Olympic
Village and you had like a one-person
crew like everything about this is very
unique so for people that don't know I
don't I hate asking the generic question
yeah talk a little bit about the film
and how you know how this thing came
together Olympic dreams is the first
feature-length fictional film ever shot
in like a real live Olympic Village we
filmed it at the curry Olympics in 2018
it stars Alexi Pappas and Nick Kroll and
Alexi is also an Olympic athlete which
is kind of how we got our into all of
this because no one's ever had the
permissions to do what we did which was
like have full access to like Olympic
dorms the dining hall the figure skating
practice rink and so it was just the
three of us I was kind of a one-man band
and the story is about Penelope who is
played by Alexi a cross-country skier
who does a personal best in her race
but still finishes like 20th or 30th
there's only three people who metal and
there's hundreds of athletes these are
all they've dedicated their lives to
this so she's kind of we pick her up in
this post race moment figuring out like
what comes next after you've
accomplished one lifelong dream and she
meets Nick plays Ezra a volunteer
dentist the Olympic Village is full of
volunteer medical staff from around the
world and Ezra is also at a crossroads
in life and these two lost souls meet at
one of the most amazing stages in the
world and have this time where they
learn about themselves well the thing
that I find so what's crazy about this
is that you guys it's like a one camera
set up if I'm not mistaken like you're
the crew or am I wrong about this no
that's true was literally Jeremy had a
camera he had a sound bag he was we
would mic ourselves and then we would
just go out in the world eat it three
lenses and he just shot he just shot and
sound did all the mixing everything
himself while we were all day long just
running around shooting like crazy how
but how does that work in terms of you
you don't I would imagine the other
athletes in the village
maybe there's a sign that we might be
making a movie or something but how does
it work in terms of maybe you get a
great shot but you have people in the
background that don't want to be in a
movie
that do you know what I mean maybe the
athlete can answer this one yeah well we
actually you know we took in the whole
Olympics as our set and I was really a
character in the story and so we tried
to be as you know discreet as possible
respectful of the Olympians of course
but also asking them to be a part of it
and so a lot of several Olympians have
roles in the movie and they were truly
in between competitions when they acted
in scenes with Nick and myself and as
for the background people that you were
talking about Olympians are super
focused on their craft like on their
race or competition and so we actually
found that people often ignored us or
were so used to cameras that they maybe
thought that we were just another media
camera around and so it it actually
worked out super well and we were lucky
to have a slates both incorporated into
the movie and also as our backdrop how
did it work in terms of you
you have an idea of where you're going
you have script but how does it work
when because I'd imagine you have access
to certain locations at certain times
how does that impact the story and what
you're trying to do with the limitations
of the locations if you will well we we
had a an outline for obviously the the
film story and largely improvised
dialogue and Jeremy as the director and
I mean literally director like upm line
producer everything in between had a
sense of where we were gonna shoot
certain scenes based on locations that
we were gonna get but oftentimes
transportation or someone wouldn't let
us inside of an event or whatever the
realities of a thing you just adapt and
you see the beauty of it is like we knew
the emotional stories points that we
need to hit we had some ideas of where
we want to shoot it
sometimes those places would be perfect
sometimes they would fall through and
the the the beauty of having just a
three-person crew is that you have
incredible mobility like we'd be in a
cab and we'd drive by a pretty location
when we would just get out of the cab
and shoot the scene and that and that's
an unbelievable
unbelievably sort of unique experience
it just felt like a full-circle
experience of you know I've been through
like making your tiny first this is my
third movie which is amazing I like
making through the first film ultra
scrappy the second film grew a little
bit and this one was like shrunk back
down to just like you and your friends
high school weekend except we were like
I had this insane intricate rig which I
don't even know how much money all the
equipment that I had on my person at one
moment was worth and then like these two
people and the Olympics like but it but
ultimately it just felt like us a group
of friends making a film and we could
pull over somewhere cool and shoot
something does it take place
in one day or is it over a few days it's
over the course of the Olympic Games so
you know and that I guess runs about two
and a half weeks three weeks yeah it's a
it's not exactly you know we don't have
a specified amount of days but it's
really over the run of the games and we
were there for about two and a half I
was there two enough weeks you guys were
there about three
and you really it really is this it's a
grind I mean the Olympics itself is like
people are competing people are going to
things you know like you come to South
by Southwest it's like a three-day thing
some people say for a week but it's you
really start to get into the flow of
that particular organism that is the
Olympics and and we just shot every day
we just worked every day that we were
there we were shooting and then and you
feel this I think you feel both the
intimacy of it and also the grandeur of
it which is a is a pretty unique feeling
I think how much one of my favorite
movies is before sunrise yeah and I'm
just curious how much are you looking at
like a movie like that and other you
know there's not too many movies like
before sunrise but look you know films
like that in terms of to see you know
maybe to inspire or look at how to tell
the story and Linklater is one of my
favorite filmmakers of all time and
absolutely I mean I think everything I
do is inspired by him just because I've
watched all of his movie so many times
and but a lot of it also was just
inspired by like Alexie's real
experience and the experience of other
athletes that we've come in contact with
just like telling a truthful story does
that seem yeah Jeremy is often described
our work as like a patchwork quilt of
sorts where it's not based on any one
experience but it's a collection of our
observations our experiences talking to
other Olympians to hopefully tell a
story that has not specifically happened
but could have happened so I think and I
think that the there but in when I when
they told me about it it was like oh
this feels a little bit like the quality
of that the essence of what before
sunrise feels like of two people
crossing over at some moment in their
life at a crossroads and they have this
moment where they're together and and
whether it will last forever or it will
be this ephemeral moment is up for grabs
and lost in translation it has elements
of that of two people sort of lost souls
in a in a very distant place who in
finding each other find some level of
connection and enjoyment
another one of my favorite films my
movie is amazing what's a day for each
of you what's a day from shooting that
you're like I cannot believe we're
standing here and we're about to film
this we had one day that I'll speak too
quickly that was it was wild we shot a
couple scenes down in the village then
we went up to the cross-country track
where we shot stuff with Lexie with her
double of her racing we shot a scene the
two of us then we took a bus down to the
opening ceremonies we shot in the
athletes holding pen right as they are
walking out into the Olympics like into
the stadium for the whole world to see
shot around there then got on a bus shot
an important emotional scene for us on
the bus ride and then ended up at a
Korean nightclub where we gorilla-like
just ran into a Korean nightclub and
grabbed a bunch of shots it was it was
pretty I mean you couldn't ask for a
more full complete very day of shooting
and it stands out to me is one of the
more interesting days of my acting
career
people are going hard in this nightclub
it was not just like a casual cash night
it was like I think I must have been
college kids like yeah it was squad
ranking um reputable and we have
fireball IRA battle yeah combined yeah
but we just slipped in with it would you
have an SLR would you for that one I put
the EBA one Panasonic Evil One was my
main guy but I had a DSLR and so that's
what I slipped into the club yeah that
first of all it's crazy but what's it
did you guys drink in the movie - in the
scenes no not really
I was going to say I wanted to know what
the secret is to playing a drunk or
being dreads it's the movies I mean
there we're out and about but it's
really I mean Alexi is an Olympic
athlete and and and also an amazing
actor and but I think it's it was sort
of this there's something about the
movie that's it's about very very adult
things in really big moments in life but
it's there's actually like a real
sweetness to it and there's kind of like
it's not it's it's it's an interesting
mix of incredibly adult themes and
actually
the there's a real like I find like a
charming innocence to it all and I think
it's it and I think that's largely what
Alexei Brinks the to the screen that
that translates that can you share a day
that for you
like that you'll always remember from
filming yeah for me the dining hall
honestly meant a lot to me because as an
Olympian the dining hall was my was my
place to just sit and people-watch and
gather myself and prepare because our
rooms you know I didn't necessarily want
to be alone when I was at the Olympics
but I didn't necessarily want to be with
specific people I just wanted to be
among my peers and the dining hall is 24
hours a day it's all of your peers
nobody's bothering you but you're able
to sit with anyone and so for us to
shoot in there felt like I don't know it
felt like someone was inside of my
dollhouse or something that I have kept
inside of my heart and and to show that
to the world in a way that I feel
comfortable and truthful about in a way
that's respectful to Olympians and and
does does good on the experience in my
opinion was such a privilege yeah I had
a being in the dining hall and I tried
to capture it on like a my phone at some
point but when you're walking down the
aisle you know there's hundreds of
thousands of athletes all eating but as
you're walking down an aisle you hear 15
different languages literally you just
all of a sudden you're you're and it's
kind of unlike anything I've ever
experienced I know there are a lot of
international festivals like that but in
this way that everybody's you're like oh
there's I think I just heard like
Japanese Estonian Korean Portuguese
you're wearing orange your uniform yeah
yeah and everybody's wearing their
uniform so you can identify where
everybody's from it's really wild you
got to experience you cheat I mean you
you got to experience something that no
regular folks will ever get to say
literally nobody nobody was hanging in
there except two athletes and their
coaches yeah and we got to shoot in
there Jeremy would we would set up a
long lens and we would shoot and nobody
had any idea that we were shooting a
scene in the middle of there because
they're just focused on their race but
it was
notice they didn't care they're just oh
that's some media person here eating
lunch they didn't know we were actually
three otters or cinema gold or they were
the the one beautiful thing was when
they did recognize Nick some of these
athletes travel on the road most of the
year and and and their their longest
lasting friend might actually be a
television show on Netflix that Nick
wrote and created and so they actually
felt a connection to him in an aspect
and a gratitude to him and Nick seemed
equally in awe of these athletes so
there was actually this tremendous you
know coming together of people at the at
the height of their you know in the in
the it you know at the top of their own
game being in the same space and and
having gratitude for each other was
really cool too one of my final
questions is that I'm always curious
about the editing process because I said
again and again it's the final rewrite
I'm just curious how the film might have
changed in the editing room and what you
learned from any early screenings you
know the the core of the story didn't
really change in the Edit I had a pretty
clear like we the three of us had really
like locked in who these characters are
I think a lot of times on like improv
heavy films like mumblecore films
especially like you figure out who your
characters are as you shoot we were like
locked in so it was actually really cool
and really refreshing a process I really
liked so like there was no stuff that
was just unusable from a story
perspective maybe from a tech
perspective cuz I was a one-man band but
actually I'm pretty proud of how much
stuff was like really really good so you
know I think we in the Edit like tried
to heighten certain like will moments of
like these characters making decisions
about what they're gonna do with the
rest of their lives like that's really
what the movies about is like being at
this pinnacle moment the Olympics and
not being sure what happens next so in
the Edit we try to find like moments
between lines of dialogue especially to
let things breathe that was a big lesson
that Paul Thomas Anderson taught me he
name-drop right no my amazing Paul saw
their first movie track town and loved
it and they they don't have to say it
but I can say it was like he really he
spoke about it a number of times which
is one of the reasons that encouraged me
to work with them and acted as a mentor
to Jeremy and in in the Edit and gave
gave some time to watch and give
thoughts and and it was really pretty
cool I mean finding mentors especially
in like the creative world Alexia's
mentors in the running world like it's
just such an important thing and so I
actually got to go to his house and
workshop a scene with him and his lesson
was really like finding these these
looks these little moments to like milk
these decision points in the Edit and
really have like a clear moment where
you see a character make a decision so
that was cool and and it's fun to like
be at a point where I can start to
mentor people who behind the camera is a
Dartmouth intern jindo who yeah it's
just great so I feel like mentoring and
being mentored is like the most fun part
of being in this like creative community
my last thing and it's I'm gonna switch
subjects as I said to you repeatedly I
am a what we call a big fan of big mouth
I think it's you know I'll say it on
camera one of the best shows on any
channel it is spectacular I just want to
know how many voices do you actually do
and have you watched online the amount
of people like doing renditions of the
songs and the fan reaction to this show
yeah I think I'm right now at least
through the first few seasons it's about
I think I do about 25 voices on the show
four or five of the leads and then
filling in stuff throughout and yeah
it's really it's been incredibly
gratifying to see people you know
especially in the way modern media
functions it's that there's the the the
piece of art that you make and then
there's the art that gets made out of
the art you're making and it's this
grilll incredible dialogue that you have
with your audience and that it becomes
this sort of organism that takes on and
mutates and takes on its and evolves and
takes on its own form and it's sort of
the highest praise for work that you do
now which
like people want to make their own
versions of it or do the voices or do
their own renditions of the song or
share and create out of it and so that
it's incredibly gratifying and I I get
to make the show with my best friend
from childhood Andrew and and friends
that I've made now throughout my life
and you think it's the best way to make
things and and I didn't know Jeremy and
Alexi going into this movie I met them
twice for five hours before we got on a
plane to Korea and then jumped into
three week intense war together and to
come out of that with friendships that
and and professional collaborations that
are incredibly gratifying is it's all
you can ask for I think when you people
when you see stuff that's made with love
you feel it on screen and and I think I
hope that we successfully done that
because it was a real labor of love and
and I couldn't have asked for better
people to make a movie with I cannot
truthfully cannot wait to see it I'm so
anxious to see the footage from like the
inside you really college it's kind of
unlike anything you've ever seen I
cannot wait and also just knowing the
technical challenges but anyway that's
for another thing yeah the three of you
thank you so much for coming in Congrats
on being part of South by and I wish you
guys nothing but the best thank you
you